Ich könnte mich auch hier
hinstellen und eine liberale Erfolgsgeschichte
darstellen, will ich aber nicht. Der Liberalismus
ist immer so "Ich stelle mich
hin und ich bin selfmade und ich habe
voll abgerissen." Alter, du hast so wenig
Einfluss auf alles, was in deinem
Leben passiert. Also auf diese Kausalkette,
die dazu führt, dass du hier stehst,
sind so so wenige Punkte, auf die du Einfluss
-hast.
-13 FRAGEN. Hier kommt die erste Frage,
nämlich: Ist der Kapitalismus am Ende?
Ja oder nein? Wenn ihr sagt eher ja,
dann begebt euch bitte aufs grüne
Feld. Wenn ihr sagt Nein, wir brauchen
den Kapitalismus, dann bitte
Richtung Gelb. Und bitte. So, vielen Dank.
Wir wissen, wo ihr steht. Die Frage
ist: Wo steht ihr? Der Kapitalismus hat ja
den meisten von uns in Deutschland
zu relativem Wohlstand verholfen
und der kapitalistische
Wettbewerb finanziert über Steuern und Abgaben
auch unseren Sozialstaat. Das nennen
wir dann "soziale Marktwirtschaft".
Viele haben aber das Gefühl, da ist
etwas in Schieflage geraten, denn Kapitalismus
steht auch für Ressourcenausbeutung,
Umweltzerstörung und extreme Ungleichheit,
die berühmte Schere zwischen Arm und Reich.
Mehr als die Hälfte der Deutschen -
und das finde ich wirklich erstaunlich
- glaubt, das derzeitige Wirtschaftssystem
schade Ihnen mehr, als dass es ihnen
hilft. Stellt sich die Frage: Was ist
die Alternative? Bei 13 FRAGEN sind
sich ja meine Gäste zumindest am Anfang
einigermaßen uneins. Heute wird
es besonders spannend, ob sie am Ende
der Folge vielleicht doch noch
zusammenkommen zu einer Art Kompromiss
oder vielleicht sogar zu einer Lösung.
Wo würdet ihr euch positionieren? Auf Grün
(der Kapitalismus ist am Ende) oder auf gelb
(Nein, wir brauchen ihn noch)?
Ganz kurz zu den Regeln.
Grundsätzlich gilt: Wenn ihr im folgenden Verlauf
der Gegenseite in einem Punkt
zustimmt, dann geht ihr bitte gerne einen Schritt
auf sie zu, also einen Schritt vor und wenn ihr sagt
"ist totaler Quatsch,
was da erzählt wird", dann könnt ihr auch einen
Schritt zurückgehen, also euch
ein wenig entfernen. Mein Ziel am Ende
muss es natürlich sein, möglichst viele
von euch hier in die Mitte zu bewegen,
dass wir im Idealfall einen Kompromiss
oder vielleicht sogar eine Lösung
zum Problem finden. Hier kommt Frage 2
und die geht ein Disarstar aka. Gerrit,
du stehst auf der Seite "Der Kapitalismus ist
am Ende" und das begründest du auch mit persönlichen
Ungerechtigkeiten, die du
-erlebt hast. Welche denn?
-Ich glaube, wenn man in einer Stadt wie
Hamburg aufwächst oder in anderen
Großstädten, Weltstädten und irgendwie
als neugieriger, wacher Junge oder Mädchen
durch die Welt geht, dann wird einem
schnell klar, dass da irgendwie
vieles nicht so ganz zusammenpasst
und dass die Balance an vielen
Stellen nicht stimmt. Und das ist die Erfahrung,
die ich gemacht habe, die ich mache von klein
auf an. Man merkt ja, wie die Eltern
arbeiten, wie Eltern mitunter sehr schwer
arbeiten und am Ende es trotzdem irgendwie
-vielleicht hier und da nicht reicht.
-Was hat das also mit Kapitalismus zu tun?
-Warum stehst du deswegen auf Grün?
-Ich glaube, dass der Wettkampf, die
Marktwirtschaft und das Grundsystem
dieser Welt quasi, dass es Gewinner und Verlierer
gibt, die Leute in einen immensen Druck
zwingt, unter dem Familien mitunter kaputt
gehen und Menschen mitunter kaputt
gehen. Und ich glaube, dass das ein Grund ist,
warum ich hier stehe. Meine primäre
Kritik am Kapitalismus ist die,
dass der Kapitalismus zwar extrem
gut darin ist, Reichtum zu produzieren,
aber extrem schlecht darin, den Reichtum
gut zu verteilen. Ich meine, wenn man
einmal irgendwie auf Sankt
Pauli durch mein Viertel geht und sich
die Ungleichheit zwischen Arm und Reich
anguckt und sich anguckt, dass die Zahl
derer, die Pfandflaschen sammeln und die Zahl
derer, die Supersportwagen fahren,
irgendwie korreliert, dann ist das glaube
ich 2021 schwierig zu sagen "Es geht mich
-nichts an, das interessiert mich nicht."
-Kapitalismus, überspitzt formuliert, ist
-also ein unmenschliches System?
-Ne, unmenschlich - das kann man
diskutieren, aber ein per se
ungerechtes auf jeden Fall.
Könnt ihr das nachvollziehen? Wenn ja,
kommt ihr nach vorne oder nicht? Du ja,
-warum?
-Ja, definitiv. Einmal, weil ich natürlich
auch die Position von dir sehr gut
verstehe aufgrund meiner eigenen
Lebensbiografie und aufgrund der Erfahrungen,
Diskriminierung
und Benachteiligung, die man auf jeden
Fall systembedingt erfährt. Für mich ist
es wichtig über den Kapitalismus zu reden,
weil ich die negativen Auswüchse
vom Kapitalismus erlebt habe. Von Eltern,
die von Arbeitslosengeld leben mussten,
die psychisch erkrankt sind, die missachtet
und stigmatisiert werden
von der Gesellschaft und Menschen, die im Niedriglohnsektor
arbeiten und von ihrem
Geld nicht leben können, wie es einst
vom Kapitalismus uns versprochen wurde.
Und deshalb ist es mir wichtig,
auch eine gewisse kritische Haltung dazu
zu entwickeln und trotzdem zu sagen,
dass der Kapitalismus alternativlos ist.
Max ist aber nach hinten gegangen
sogar. Also du standest schon ganz hinten,
aber bist lieber nochmal so ein kleines
Schritt...das war ein Ausrufezeichen.
-Warum bist du nach hinten gegangen?
-Na also ich glaube, dass das Thema
Ausbeutung oder auch das, was ja
immer in der Politik gesagt wird, Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich, ist kein
grundsätzlich kapitalistisches Problem,
sondern ich glaube, dass ist das Streben
des Menschen nach Wohlstand,
nach Anerkennung, nach Erreichen
seiner Ziele. Ich glaube, viele Menschen
und es wird ja leider auch ideologisch,
es ist ja auch sehr populistisch geprägt
dieser Begriff Kapitalismus. Manchmal
ist es natürlich einfacher, die Verantwortung
abzugeben, zu sagen ja, der böse
Kapitalist ist schuld, der böse
Unternehmer ist schuld. Aber am Ende
des Tages ist Kapitalismus frei und es ist
halt selbstbestimmt. Jeder kann
halt selber entscheiden, wie er sich
in diesem System verwirklichen
möchte. Und es gibt diverse Armutsforschung,
die beweisen, dass durch den Kapitalismus,
durch dieses effiziente Verwenden
von Ressourcen die Armut weltweit
seit dem 18. Jahrhundert eher abgenommen hat,
-als dass sie stärker geworden ist.
-Darf ich da direkt widersprechen?
Ja klar, du darfst
widersprechen, natürlich.
Also das hat das System an sich, dass es das Kapital
akkumuliert auf der einen
Seite und dass andere Leute
ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen,
um überhaupt leben zu können. Und die Idee,
des Kapitalismus ist nicht Wohlstand
zu generieren, das ist vielleicht
ein Nebeneffekt der letzten 60 Jahre.
Und das ist aber durch soziale
Kämpfe entstanden und nicht dadurch,
dass der Kapitalismus total, ja,
den Wohlstand der Menschen im Blick hat.
Sondern es geht um Kapitalakkumulation
und um nichts mehr. Ich selbst will nicht
länger an einem Wirtschaftssystem
leben, das auf Ausbeutung von Natur und Menschen
beruht und in dem andere die Kosten
für meine Lebensweise tragen und stattdessen
in einem Gesellschaftssystem, in dem die Bedürfnisse
der Menschen im Mittelgrund
stehen. Indem wir das produzieren
und konsumieren, was wir wirklich brauchen
und in dem wir Zeit haben für die Dinge,
die uns wirklich glücklich machen.
Naja, aber da will ich doch nochmal
kurz einführen, dass der Mensch eine Sache
entwickelt hat, die wir alle
gemeinsam haben, nämlich Vernunft. Und warum hat
der Mensch Vernunft entwickelt? Um Glück
nachzustreben. Aus welchem Ausbeutung
zum Beispiel resultieren kann. Und so
ist z.B. auch klar, dass wir soziale Regeln
benötigen, soziale
Regeln für ein Miteinander.
Würdest du sagen, viele
Menschen sind glücklich in diesem System?
-Wie bitte?
-Würdest du sagen, viele Leute sind
glücklich in diesem System? Also wenn ich mich
umschaue und mit Leuten spreche,
dann habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass ihre 40
bis 50 Stundenwoche sie krass glücklich
macht. Oder wenn sie danach irgendwie
schön shoppen gehen können oder sich alle
zwei Jahre ein neues Smartphone
kaufen, dass das wirklich die Essenz von Glück
ist. Die meisten Leute sagen:
Die Familie, Beziehungen, das ist das,
was sie glücklich macht. Und zum Punkt
Vernunft: Also ich finde, der Kapitalismus
ist das irrationalste, was wir uns
vorstellen können. Also wir sägen den Ast
ab, auf dem wir sitzen und sind
wie diese drei Affen, die sich die Ohren
und die Augen zuhalten und unsere Lebensgrundlagen
zerstören.
Ich bin voll auf deiner Seite
insofern, weil ich glaube, dass die 40 bis 50
Stunden Woche ein total
veraltetes System ist und aus der Zeit
der Industrialisierung
kommt. Und entsprechend sehe ich mich
in der Situation zu sehen, wie können
wir innerhalb des kapitalistischen Systems
durch Regulierung, durch
neue Sozialstaatskonzepte etc.
mehr Gerechtigkeit und mehr
Solidarität erringen? Und ich glaube,
dass dieses System das Beste
ist, das wir haben.
Und das sieht Génica offenbar
ähnlich, denn du bist nach vorne gelaufen gerade.
Ich bin auch nach vorne gelaufen,
genau, weil ich auch Ronjas Meinung bin. Also
zum einen: Ich glaube nicht,
dass Leute gerade absolut glücklich sind
in diesem System. Es gibt vereinzelt
Leute, die gewinnen dadurch, dass andere
ausgebeutet werden und wir sägen
wirklich den Ast ab. Ich kann total gut
nachvollziehen, dass man sagt, der Kapitalismus
ist am Ende, weil Fakt ist,
wir stoßen an unsere planetaren
Grenzen und Menschen bleiben auf der Strecke,
während andere profitieren. Aber für mich
fehlt es einfach noch an realistischen
Alternativen, die es direkt
umzusetzen gilt. Also der Kapitalismus ist ja
auch ein sehr freies System, in dem super
viel Raum für Experimente ist und es gibt
unterschiedliche Ansätze. Vielleicht
muss man die einfach mal ein bisschen stärker
fördern, damit Menschen auch z.B.
anfangen, ihre Arbeit zu schätzen.
Und darüber werden wir definitiv
noch sprechen, denn du hast ja ein Beispiel
quasi mitgebracht. Ich will nur, weil ich ihn
noch nicht gehört habe, Kofi nochmal
reinbringen. Er sagt, es ist das beste
System, das wir haben, es gehört
reformiert und reguliert.
Wie siehst du das?
Ich würde sagen, es ist das schlechteste
System, das wir haben, weil es seit seiner
Existenz eigentlich nur Armut und Leid
erzeugt. Leute, die der Meinung sind,
dass nur der Kapitalismus Freiheit oder Fortschritt
ermöglichen kann, sehen nicht,
dass das nur für einen kleinen Teil
der Menschheit gilt, während die Mehrheit
davon nicht profitiert, sondern im Gegensatz
eben unterdrückt wird,
unter Armut leidet. Sobald auf der einen
Seite Reichtum entsteht, entsteht
auf der anderen Seite in noch
größerem Maße Armut und Leid. Natürlich geht
es da auch um den globalen Süden,
der seit der Entstehung des Kapitalismus
auf verschiedene Arten ausgebeutet
wurde. Sei es der Handel mit versklavten Menschen
in die Amerikas und die Karibik, um dort
Rohstoffe zu plündern und dann nach Europa
zu bringen, was unter anderem auch die Entstehung
des Kapitalismus in dem Sinne
erst ermöglicht hat und dann in der zweiten
Phase mehr oder weniger
die komplette Aufteilung der Welt in Kolonien
und abhängige Länder, von denen
viele heute auch noch nicht
unabhängig sind, politisch und wirtschaftlich
-gesehen.
-Wie geht's euch damit? Glaubt ihr, das
System ist in sich faul? Oder glaubt
ihr, dieses System kann innerhalb sich selbst
quasi reformiert werden und auf die Beine
und auf die Füße gestellt werden?
Jetzt sagt Kofi, Max, der globale
Norden hat quasi auf dem Rücken des globalen
Südens Ressourcen ausgebeutet und hat
dadurch seinen auch finanziellen Wohlstand
erst erreicht. Kannst du
das nachvollziehen? Es ist glaube
ich auch eine unstrittige
These, aber was antwortet du ihm?
Es ist eine unstrittige
These, da stimme ich auch zu.
-Und kommst nach vorne?
-Ich komme einen kleinen Schritt nach
vorne, dass das früher tatsächlich
so war. Ich glaube auch, dass das heute
in gewissen kleinen
Teilen der Welt immer noch so ist.
-What?
-Ich bin mir auch bewusst, dass viele
Menschen auch noch darunter leiden.
Aber wenn man das jetzt untersuchen möchte,
es gibt so etwas, das nennt sich
Pareto Effizienz im Bereich Wirtschaft.
Und das untersucht beispielsweise ein ganz
einfaches Beispiel: Ich bin Bauer und hab
einen Acker und ich möchte
Pflanzen und Blumen anbauen, dann hat man
nur eine bestimmte Fläche an Acker und man
muss halt entscheiden, wie viel Blumen
möchte ich anbauen oder wieviel
Gemüse möchte ich anbauen? Und das ist halt so
der Zielkonflikt, den man hat. Und ich lebe
lieber in einem freiheitsorientierten
System, weil das ist Kapitalismus.
Und der Sozialismus hat aus meiner Sicht
den Gerechtigkeitsanspruch, aber in meiner
Aufassung hat der Kapitalismus mehr
-Vorteile als Nachteile.
-Ja gut, Kofi hat ja jetzt gerade nicht
über Sozialismus gesprochen, sondern dass der Kapitalismus
ein per se ungerechtes
-System, global gesehen, ist.
-Ich merke auch richtig, mir geht so
richtig das Messer in der Tasche
auf, wenn ich das höre, weil ich mir denke,
wir externalisieren die ganze Zeit
die Kosten für unsere imperiale Lebensweise.
Und von wegen Ausbeutung führt jetzt
nicht mehr irgendwie zu extremer Armut. Es gibt
immer noch koloniale Strukturen. Die Kobaltminen
im Kongo, die Zerstörung des
Nigerdeltas in Nigeria. Für unsere Rohstoffe
beuten wir konsequent
und die ganze Zeit andere Teile der Welt
aus. Andere Menschen werden enteignet,
vertrieben und verlieren ihre Lebensgrundlagen.
Und wir stehen hier
und sagen Ja, wir leben aber in relativen
Wohlstand. Da denke ich mir so: Ich will
nicht mehr so krass auf Kosten anderer
leben und deswegen brauchen wir ein neues
-Wirtschaftssystem.
-Ich muss daran kurz anknüpfen, weil auch
das Beispiel, das du gebracht
hast, Max: Viele von diesen ökonomischen
Gedankenspielen sind sehr isoliert
und isolieren Menschen und betrachten
sie nicht in dem sozialen Kontext, in dem sie leben.
Also hat ein Bauer, ob er jetzt
in einem afrikanischen Land lebt
oder in Südostasien oder in Lateinamerika,
wirklich die Freiheit zu entscheiden,
was er überhaupt produzieren will,
wenn sein Saatgut wahrscheinlich
monopolisiert ist von Monsanto oder einem
anderen Konzern. Also ist die Frage:
Wo ist am Ende die Freiheit, von der immer
-die Rede ist?
-Warum glaubst du ist ist der Kapitalismus
das Wirtschaftssystem, das uns
auch menschlich oder gesellschaftlich
-weiterbringt?
-Kapitalismus als solcher, stellt nicht
unbedingt die Gerechtigkeitsfrage,
sondern es ist die die Freiheitsfrage.
Also Kapitalismus ist das System,
was die größte Freiheit bringt?
Also wenn man das jetzt von den Ursprüngen
von 1820 betrachtet, wo das die reinste
Form des Kapitalismus ist, dann
ist es das freiheitorientierteste System.
Und für mich bedeutet Kapitalismus,
dass er eins der fairsten Systeme ist,
weil auch das Beispiel mit den Bauern.
Damals in der chinesischen Revolution ist
es tatsächlich so gewesen, dass die Bauern,
also ich sag mal die ärmste
Bevölkerungsschicht, sich darüber
aufgeregt hat, dass es keinen freien
Wettbewerb gibt und dass sie keinen
finanziellen Anreiz haben, sozusagen mehr
zu verdienen, mehr zu machen, weil sie immer
am Existenzminimum gelebt haben.
Und dann haben ja quasi die chinesischen
Bauern das System gekippt. Also ich glaube
auch, dass diese Effizienz
des kapitalistischen Systems durch
diese Profitgier, durch diese Gewinnmaximierung
genau ein Ziel hat:
Dass man Ressourcen so
effizient wie möglich einsetzt.
Ok, dann lass uns das mal mitnehmen.
Also du sagst, Kapitalismus bringt ein hohes
Maß an Freiheit, ein hohes Maß an Effizienz,
gute Nutzung von potenziellen
-Ressourcen.
-Innovation, Wohlstand...
Innovation, Wohlstand. Das sind
jetzt schon fünf Punkte, wer will antworten?
-Ronja?
-Also vielleicht kann man grundsätzlich ein
paar kleine Zugeständnisse
dahingehend machen, dass wir, die Menschheit,
sich irgendwie in einem
dialektischen Prozess befindet und natürlich
der Kapitalismus auf vielen
Ebenen, auf einigen auch nicht, ein Upgrade
zu vorangegangenen Systemen ist.
Aber es ist geschichtsrevisionistisch davon
auszugehen in Anbetracht dieser Geschichte,
dass der Kapitalismus das Ende
der Geschichte wäre. Und diese ganzen
Attribute, die aufgezählt werden,
wie Innovation, das kann sein. Aber
darüber hinaus sind diese ganzen Sachen
halt einfach Etikettenschwindel. Also
das ist das, wie sich Liberale das zurecht
drehen, ihr perfektes System. Aber das hat
mit den Lebensrealitäten auf der Straße
und mit den Lebensrealitäten
der Menschen überhaupt nichts zu tun.
-Ronja, du bezweifelst das auch?
-Ja, ich würde gerne über diesen
Freiheitsbegriff nochmal
nachdenken. Weil was für eine Freiheit ist das?
Für die Kapitalfraktionen ist es die Freiheit
zu investieren in was sie wollen.
Und das ist auf keinen Fall oder in den seltensten
Fällen in irgendeiner Form
dem Gemeinwohl dienlich. Und für uns
Lohnabhängigen ist es die Freiheit
zu konsumieren. Mehr bietet uns dieses System
nicht. Und alles, was uns wirklich
glücklich macht, findet dann
irgendwie in den Sparten dazwischen statt.
Die Freiheit also auch vom Staat? Also
der Staat sagt mir nicht, was ich zu tun habe,
-das ist ja auch die Freiheit.
-Die ganzen real existierenden
Sozialismus-Beispiele, ich würde
die nie verteidigen. Das sind höchst
undemokratische Systeme. Und ich würde
auch nicht sagen, dass der Staat all
unsere Probleme löst. Also wir müssen
vergesellschaften. Wir müssen nicht
verstaatlichen, sondern vergesellschaften.
Wir brauchen eine ganz andere Art
zu leben, zu wirtschaften,
miteinander umzugehen. Die wir uns jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht vorstellen können. Und diese Idee
von "Wachstum bringt Wohlstand".
Ich würde sagen, Wohlstand kann
es langfristig nur ohne Wachstum geben,
weil die ökologische Krise ist so
massiv. Wir stehen kurz vor dem ökologischen
Kollaps. Die Klimakrise ist nur ein Punkt
davon. Und ich glaube, wir können uns alle
gar nicht vorstellen, was passiert,
wenn wir auf diese drei bis vier Grad heißere
-Welt zusteuern.
-Und ein Stichwort, was Ronja gegeben hat,
war das Stichwort Wachstum.
Wachstum ist zumindest in unserer medialen
Öffentlichkeit irgendwie meistens
irgendwie gut konnotiert. Was findet
-ihr daran beklagenswert?
-Wachstum kann nicht ins Unermessliche
gehen, also das sowieso nicht. Und am Ende
des Tages hat man Kriegsnot. Am Ende des
Tages sind die natürlichen Ressourcen
ausgebeutet. Und das ist ja das Witzige,
also das ist ja das Absurde bei dieser Debatte,
weil das ist eine historische
Einzigartigkeit am Kapitalismus, dass er den Planeten
dermaßen zerstört, was kein
vorangegangenes System oder keine
vorangegangene Gesellschaftsordnung jemals
gemacht hat. Das heißt, diese Frage
"wollen wir den Kapitalismus überwinden?"
ist meines Erachtens nach völlig
obsolet, weil ich tausendprozentig davon überzeugt
bin, dass solange irgendwie die Freiheit
im Kapitalismus die Freiheit der Reichen
ist, das Verwertungsprinzip oder die Verwertungslogik
über allem steht,
werden wir auch was Umweltschutz
angeht, nicht an den Punkt kommen,
dass wir die bestehenden
Verhältnisse so runterfahren, dass dieser Planet
in was weiß ich wie vielen
Jahren noch bewohnbar ist.
Das ist ja ganz interessant. Jetzt
darf Génica, die war schon lange nicht dran.
Du siehst ja, wenn ich das zumindest
so richtig im Kopf habe, vieles,
was er gerade gesagt hat, sogar
ganz ähnlich, ne? Also ein stetiges
Wirtschaftswachstum und immer
wieder an diese Prozente denken, das habt
ihr in deinem Job ja eben nicht auf eure Fahnen
geschrieben. Da steht nicht
Profitmaximierung drin, sondern was ganz
anderes eigentlich. Nämlich was?
Also man könnte sagen, bei uns
steht auch Profitmaximierung im Zentrum,
allerdings nicht Profite oder Gewinne
als Selbstzweck, wie es ganz oft passiert
im Kapitalismus, sondern als Mittel
zum Zweck, um etwas Gutes zu bewirken.
Also ich arbeite bei Ecosia, das ist
eine Suchmaschine, die Bäume pflanzt
und die Bäume werden finanziert durch
die Gewinne aus Werbeanzeigen und da gibt's
keine Shareholder, die irgendwas
rausnehmen. Wenn wäre auch okay, aber
die Maximierung, die findet statt,
um Gemeinwohl zu stiften, um für andere
etwas zu tun. Ich finde, das ist
eigentlich die Daseinsberechtigung
von Unternehmen, nämlich
der Gesellschaft zu dienen.
-Interessanter Punkt.
-Also für alle, die das nicht verstehen,
weil sie nicht ganz so tief drin sind.
Also sie haben ein gemeinwohlorientiertes
Unternehmen. Ihr pflanzt Bäume mit den Gewinnen,
die ihr durch Werbung z.B.
-macht, wie eine Suchmaschine halt, ne?
-Genau.
So wie Google es macht. Nur Google
behält das Geld und ihr...
-Oder gibt es an die Shareholder.
-Genau oder gibt es an die Shareholder und
ihr gebt es weiter. Und das Interessante
ist ja auch: Das Unternehmen gehört euch
quasi selbst. Das kann man nicht
mehr verkaufen, das kann man nicht mehr
irgendwie auf dem freien Markt hin und her
schieben. Ist das nicht was, wo ihr sagt,
da könnt ihr anknüpfen? Also ja,
innerhalb eines kapitalistischen Systems werden aber
Gewinne eben nicht zum Selbstzweck
genommen, sondern um z.B. die Umwelt
zu retten. Genau das,
was du grad angesprochen hast.
Ich finde das super, was Ecosia
macht. Und so als einzelnes Unternehmen denke
-ich mir: Go for it.
-Es gibt ja nicht nur Ecosia. Es gibt ja
viele Sozialunternehmen, die sich
das wirklich als Aufgabe gestellt haben.
Es gibt auch traditionelle
Familienunternehmen, die diese Idee
vom ehrbaren Kaufmann weiter leben
und sagen: Wir bauen Fenster und wir wollen
richtig gute Fenster bauen, weil Menschen
das brauchen. Also das ist ja Teil des
-Kapitalismus.
-Also ich will das auch überhaupt nicht
irgendwie wegreden oder irgendwie
sagen, dass das kein Verdienst wäre und irgendwie
Wiederbeweidung - sowas ist eine total
wichtige Sache, gerade in diesem System.
Ich glaube nur, dass es auf einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Ebene trotzdem
nicht funktioniert, weil wir an die planetaren
Grenzen stoßen. Also
weil die Kapitalfraktionen miteinander
in Konkurrenz stehen und immer weiter wachsen
-müssen, um sich gegenseitig auszubooten.
-Ich glaube, die Positionen sind jetzt zu
diesem Zeitpunkt relativ klar geworden.
Oder, was meint ihr? Ich würde jetzt gerne
in unsere letzte Runde reingehen,
nämlich der Suche nach Kompromissen. Wir machen
das folgendermaßen: Ich habe mir einen
ausgedacht. Ihr könnt zustimmen, ihr müsst
nicht zustimmen. Aber mein Ziel ist
es, euch näher zusammenzubringen. Hier kommt
mein erster Kompromissvorschlag. Ihr könnt
ihn ja mal anhören und dann werden
wir sehen. Menschen in Armut haben
derzeit in Deutschland viel schlechtere
Aufstiegschancen als diejenigen
der sogenannten Mittel- und Oberschicht.
Erstes Ziel einer verantwortungsvollen
Wirtschaftspolitik muss deshalb sein,
Chancengleichheit herzustellen und Armutsrisiko
zu minimieren. Wer zustimmt,
-darf einen Schritt nach vorne kommen.
-Als erster Schritt wohin?
Darf ich direkt dazu was sagen?
Es ist halt so, das ist diese liberale
Startgerechtigkeit, die immer
gepredigt wird. Aber selbst wenn, was völlig,
völlig absurd ist, was niemals
passieren wird, selbst wenn man gleiche
Startvoraussetzungen für alle
schaffen würde, was nicht passieren wird, gibt's
in diesem System trotzdem am Ende
Gewinner und Verlierer. Und wenn alle die gleichen
Chancen hätten aufzusteigen, dann
könnten trotzdem nicht alle aufsteigen.
Das mag sein, es war ja ein Kompromissvorschlag.
Du musst nicht
-zustimmen. Ihr seid nach vorne gegangen?
-Ich finde es ein bisschen problematisch,
dass ihr hier trotzdem steht. Und das finde
ich manchmal auch ein bisschen
problematisch, weil es geht ja
jetzt so insgesamt um die Lebensverbesserung
in einem System, in dem wir uns
befinden. Und ich sehe in dem Fall eine leicht
totalitäre Haltung die ihr habt,
aufgrund der Tatsache, dass ihr diese Position
-innehalten könnt.
-Ich finde diese Vorstellung, wenn ich mir
-Freunde...
-Lass ihn ganz kurz ausreden, danach darfst
-du.
-Und es geht mir jetzt wirklich
realpolitisch um die 2,8 Millionen
Kinder und Jugendlichen, die sich nun mal
in diesem System befinden, in dem gewisse
Umstände so vorzufinden sind.
Rein realpolitisch gesprochen. Und innerhalb des
Systems finde ich das schon
auch im Namen der 2,8 Millionen
Kinder, der 600 000 Langzeitarbeitslosen.
Ist eigentlich schon fair, wenn man
sagt, in dem System, in dem wir uns befinden,
sollten wir vielleicht schon
einen Schritt vorgehen. Und ich finde
das auch ein Problem, weil da merkt
man, das ist ideologisch gerade geführt.
Ne, es ist so: Es gibt Kinder, die kommen
schwarz auf die Welt. Es gibt Kinder,
die kommen weiß auf die Welt, als Mann,
als Frau, als sportlicher Typ,
als Körperklaus, behindert,
mehr intelligent, weniger intelligent.
Diese Vorstellung von Chancengleichheit
herstellen. Ich bin
für eine Zielgerechtigkeit. Ich will
nicht, dass alle die gleiche Chance
auf ein gutes Leben haben, ich will,
dass alle ein gutes Leben haben.
Und deswegen gehe ich keinen
Schritt nach vorne, weil ich die Reformation
dieses per se schlechten Systems, per se
ungerechten Systems für unwahrscheinlicher
-halte als die Überwindung dessen.
-Wir reden über kleine Schritte, darum geht
-es. Du musst ja nicht zustimmen.
-Aber die Frage ist: Kleine Schritte wohin?
Weil eine Zielgerechtigkeit im Sinne
von Startgerechtigkeit, also ich finde, er hat
es ziemlich gut auf den Punkt
gebracht. Also wenn wir das erweitern im Sinne
von Chancengleichheit ist der erste
Schritt einer sozialökologischen
Transformation, ja, meinetwegen,
dann würde ich hier auch einen Schritt
nach vorne gehen. Aber wenn es darum geht
zu sagen, ihr dürft danach alle richtig
doll ballern und irgendwie euch
hier Ellenbogen Konkurrenz und dann schafft
ihr es vielleicht ganz nach oben...
dann kann ich da einfach nicht zustimmen.
Ihr wollt alle so viel sagen. Ich würde
gerne weiterkommen. Wie kriegen
wir das hin, dass wir jetzt unsere Köpfe
zusammenstecken? Dann sagt ihr beiden noch
-was, komm.
-Was ich noch sagen will: Eines, was ich
realisiere. Ich komme aus der unteren
Klasse dieses Landes. Ich komme aus einem
Haushalt, in dem meine Eltern
auch schon Teil der unteren Klasse waren.
Und ich sehe das in meinem Leben
und da stimme ich euch auch: Es hat viel
mit Glück zu tun in Momenten, in denen
mir spezifisch geholfen wurde
aufgrund der Momente. Das ist unfair
und das ist etwas, womit ich nicht wirklich
einstimmen kann, weshalb ich auch voll
d' accord bin. Aber ich sehe mich immer
in diesem Konflikt. Ich sehe, wir leben
in diesem System und ich glaube nicht,
dass es eine Alternative geben mag
aufgrund der Tatsache, weil wir alle schon
sehr oder viele von uns wohl
eingesessen sind. Also da sehe ich eure Position
auf jeden Fall und unterstreich
sie auch total.
Ok, dann wollte Max noch was sagen.
Danach gehen wir in die Kompromisse.
Ich würde gerne nochmal einen Punkt
oder ein wichtiges Merkmal von Kapitalismus
herausstellen. Kapitalismus ist
frei. Also jeder hat die Möglichkeit
es zu entscheiden, was er quasi
damit macht. Also wir reden jetzt nicht über
die Menschen, die wollen und nicht
können, sondern wir reden über die Menschen,
die manchmal vielleicht auch sagen
wir es mal nicht so fleißig sind wie andere.
Und davon gibt's auch ganz, ganz viele
Menschen. Und aus meiner unternehmerischen
Tätigkeit kann ich das einfach so
sagen: Es bedeutet am Anfang auch Fleiß,
mehr arbeiten und mehr machen. Und jetzt
ist es die Frage: Ist es denn gerecht,
dass jemand, der viel mehr leisten
möchte, nicht kann, sondern möchte, genau
das Gleiche verdient? Weil ja auch immer
so diese Sachen Bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen, alle Menschen haben
gleich viel... Ist es denn gerecht, dass jemand,
-der viel mehr leisten möchte...
-Niemand leistet mehr als eine
Krankenschwester in der Nachtschicht.
Verdient die am meisten? Das ist doch
Quatsch. Also es ist doch am Ende.
Sorry, aber das ist am Ende des Tages...
Aber du verdienst selber dein Geld
mit kapitalistischen Grundzügen.
Aber ich weiß genau so wie Jeremias,
was für eine Kausalkette und an wie vielen
Stellen ich in meinem Leben Glück
hatte. Ich kann mich auch hier hinstellen
und eine liberale
Erfolgsgeschichte darstellen. Will ich aber nicht,
weil ich weiß, an wie vielen
Stellen ich die richtigen Leute zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt an den richtigen Stellen
irgendwie getroffen habe, dass ich heute
da bin, wo ich bin. Und ich weiß,
dass ganz viele andere auch aus meinem
persönlichen Umfeld nicht das Glück
hatten Person XY und dann bin ich von Natur
aus nicht besonders auf den Kopf
gefallen, was irgendwie auch nochmal Bonus ist.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ein weißer Mann,
ich bin relativ groß, ich war immer sportlich.
Das sind alles Aspekte, auf die habe
ich überhaupt gar keinen Einfluss.
Und der Liberalismus ist immer so:
Ich stelle mich hin und ich bin selfmade
und ich hab voll abgerissen.
Alter, du hast so wenig Einfluss auf alles,
was in deinem Leben passiert. Also auf diese Kausalkette,
die dazu führt, dass du
hier stehst, sind so so wenige
Punkte, auf die du Einfluss hast.
Ihr werdet heute nicht mehr den Kapitalismus
abschaffen und ihr werdet
heute kein neues System bei denen
installieren. Das ist vollkommen klar.
So weit sind wir schon. Also nur, dass wir uns
klar verstehen. Ich bin auch nicht
total naiv. Aber trotzdem müssen
ja diese beiden Meinungen. Wir sind
eine Gesellschaft, es bleibt uns
nichts anderes übrig, als aufeinander zuzugehen,
also versuch es bitte. Vielleicht
finden wir es raus, vielleicht klappt
es auch nicht, wir werden sehen.
Okay, steckt die Köpfe zusammen und brütet
eine Idee aus. Wer hätte gedacht,
dass es dann doch irgendwie hitzig zugeht.
Vollkommen klar bei diesem Thema.
Da prallen einfach verschiedene Welten
aufeinander. Wenn wir nicht
wollen, dass diese Gesellschaft vollkommen
gegen die Wand fährt, bleibt uns ja
nichts anderes übrig, als uns aufeinander
zu zubewegen. Also wenn ihr einen
Vorschlag habt, dann schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare. Okay, wir starten
mal mit der gelben Seite. Diejenigen,
die den Kapitalismus noch nicht
gleich sofort abschaffen wollen, bis jetzt,
vielleicht ist ja euer Kompromissvorschlag
ein ganz anderer. Bitte.
Unser Kompromissvorschlag ist
einmal Internationalisierung dieses ganzen
Diskurses. Deswegen die internationale
Vermögenssteuer, um zu gucken, dass keine
Steuerschlupflöcher
kommen. Eine verpflichtende
Gemeinwohlökonomie-Bilanzierung
für Unternehmen, das heißt
neben dem Nachhaltigkeitsbericht,
Geschäftsbericht, sollen sie angeben,
wie viel Beitrag haben sie eigentlich
geleistet zum Gemeinwohl? Und dann gibt
es ein Punktesystem, da kann man die vergleichen,
auch als Konsument, das ist
-dann ganz einfach einsehbar.
-Was es auch schon gibt übrigens.
Was es gibt aber noch nicht
verpflichtend. Und ein ganz transparentes Lobby-Register
-und ich habe bestimmt etwas vergessen.
-Ich glaube, wir haben da vielleicht sogar
einen Kompromiss. Aber ich finde
zum Beispiel ganz spannend: Einen
solidarischen Bildungsbeitrag. So
wie so ein Solidaritätsbeitrag gibt, soll
es auch einen solidarischen
Bildungsbeitrag geben, der quasi gebunden
an diese Ausgaben ist, dass man
quasi in Bildung reinvestiert. Im deutschen
Bildungssystem fehlen 70
Milliarden Euro und Bildung ist
auch ein Einkommensprivileg
und das sollte so verhindert werden.
Okay, ich fasse kurz zusammen:
Euer Vorschlag besteht aus internationaler
Vermögenssteuer, einem
Lobbyregister, einer verpflichtenden
Gemeinwohlorientierung für Unternehmen
und einem erhöhten Bildungs-
und Solidaritätsbeitrag. Ist das mal
ein Maßnahmenbündel? Könntet ihr sagen,
immerhin mal ein richtiger...Ja ja, ja
doch. Du gehst aber mehr widerwillig mit,
-so "ja okay".
-Also wenn wir damit anfangen, wäre das
-top.
-Das wäre doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
Aber es ist nicht der Zielhorizont,
aber es wären gute erste Schritte.
"Gute erste Schritte", immerhin. So,
jetzt seid ihr dran. Wie kriegt ihr die drei
-noch näher zu euch?
-Ja, also wir haben uns überlegt, dass es
vor allem darum geht, was Menschen
zum Leben brauchen. Wir sind der Meinung,
so die tägliche
Infrastruktur des menschlichen Lebens sollte
vergesellschaftet werden z.B.
Wohnungen, aber auch das Gesundheitswesen, also
die Krankenhäuser wieder in öffentliche
Hand geben. Nicht so wie jetzt
ein Gesundheitssystem, das nur auf Profit
aus ist. Das sieht man ja auch momentan,
was nicht funktioniert und dann eben
auch so für Lebensmittelsicherheit sorgen.
-Luft, Wasser, Strom?
-Also die Grundinfrastrukturen des
alltäglichen Lebens vergesellschaftet
und der Kapitalakkumulation und dem Profit
-entzogen.
-Alles verstanden?
-Ja.
-Stimmt ihr zu? Ja, nein? Wenn ja, dann
bitte einen Schritt
vor. Wenn nein, bleibt stehen.
Uns ging es jetzt um die absoluten
Grundbedürfnisse: Lebensmittel, Wohnraum,
Gesundheit sollten keiner
Verwertungslogik unterworfen sein, sollte niemand mit Geld
verdienen, sollte absolutes
Menschenrecht für jeden in gleichem Maße zugänglich
sein. Und das heißt nicht, dass man
da dann irgendwie eine Zweiklassenmedizin
am Ende draus macht,
sondern dass jeder alles bekommt.
-Finde ich sehr gut.
-Du bleibst stehen?
Ich finde die Idee gut, also ich gehe
einen Schritt nach vorne, aber ich frage
-mich, wie das finanziert wird, aber ja.
-Wir backen uns unsere Welt.
Ganz persönlich finde ich richtig
cool zu merken, dass wir eigentlich alle
was ähnliches wollen. Nämlich wir wollen,
dass es Menschen besser geht. Wir wollen,
dass Ökologie mehr respektiert wird,
nur der Weg dahin, da unterscheiden wir uns
ein bisschen, aber haben
uns auch ein bisschen angenähert.
Es war auf jeden Fall auch extrem
überrascht über unsere Konsensvorschläge.
Und denke mir, wenn wir damit starten,
dann sind wir auf einem richtig guten Weg.
Also auch wenn mich natürlich auch viele
Sachen triggern, die irgendwie Max sagt,
bin ich froh, dass ich in so
einen Raum komme, wo ich irgendwie mich
-mit diesen Positionen konfrontieren muss.
-Ich glaube, das ist nur meine Überzeugung,
mein persönlicher Standpunkt, dass Kapitalismus,
Gerechtigkeit, Klimaschutz,
faire Bezahlung, das sind nicht
Dinge, die sich unbedingt ausschließen müssen.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass man
Konzerne, egal ob sie in Deutschland
oder in anderen Teilen der Welt
Menschen ausbeuten, einen Riegel vorschiebt.
Dass man verhindert, dass Profitstreben
dazu führt, dass die Lebensgrundlage
von Menschen untergraben wird, dass das Wohl
von Menschen darunter leidet,
-dass deutsche Konzerne profitieren wollen.
-Wenn ich mich darauf irgendwo fokussieren
müsste, fände ich ein neues
Sozialstaatskonzept wichtig,
in dem wir den Sozialstaat neu
definieren anstatt als das, woraufhin wir ihn soweit
definiert haben, nämlich auf arbeitsmarktpolitische
Reformen.
Einmal ganz wichtig: Eine Kindergrundsicherung,
indem man junge
Menschen mit 300 Euro fördert.
Unabhängig, dass man Kindergeld an ALG II anrechnet
und somit das Kind
strukturell benachteiligt. Ich finde,
Kinderrechte sollen in das Grundgesetz
reinkommen.
Ohne Scheiß, mich begeistert dein Optimismus,
finde ich schön. Ich glaube
auch, dass wir Jeremias auf dem parteipolitischen
Parkett auch noch
-in anderer Form erleben werden.
-Bist ein geiler Typ ey, ohne Scheiß.
-Danke, gleichfalls.
-Ich bin sehr tatsächlich freudig
überrascht, dass diese Kompromisrunde
nochmal ein ganz schönes Stückchen
zusammengekommen ist, wohlwissend,
dass hier auch harte Meinungen aufeinander
geprallt sind. Das ist ja vollkommen
eindeutig. Ich danke euch ganz herzlich
dafür, dass ihr euch eingebracht habt.
Das waren 13 FRAGEN. Dankeschön! Ich denke,
es ist klar geworden, so
ziemlich alle in dieser Runde wollen
dieses Wirtschaftssystem verbessern,
die Frage ist natürlich, wie? Nach meinem
Eindruck müssten wir eigentlich nur das System
ernst nehmen, das wir eigentlich
schon haben, nämlich echte
soziale Marktwirtschaft. Wenn euch 13 FRAGEN
gefällt, dann könnt ihr hier
unseren Kanal abonnieren. Hier oben findet
ihr ein weiteres Video von 13
FRAGEN und hier ein weiteres Video zum Thema.
Ich danke euch.